2020 is the year of the Xbox series X
but Microsoft isn't forgetting about the
regular Xbox one just yet
the latest dashboard update for the
console has arrived for testers at least
and it's a big one
the Xbox one UI is notorious for being
difficult to use but this update
improves things update 2002 which makes
me wonder if there have been 2001
updates before this is now available for
people in the Xbox Insider alpha ring
and in this video we're covering five
new features that make the console look
and perform even better
starting off you will immediately notice
that the homescreen is now much more
streamlined the so-called twists at the
top of the screen have been removed with
those gone the screen is less cluttered
so you can see more of it at a glance
you'll notice new smaller tiles for your
most played games and apps and below
that you'll see spotlight advertisements
for things like mixer deals and more
with all the freed up space you wonder
if Microsoft will eventually fill it
with ads but time will tell
scrolling further down the page you'll
see new rows for game paths
store mixer and community along with
individual games further down the page
hovering over these you'll see a preview
of its contents at a glance for example
the game pastro shows you big tiles for
games recommended to you i have the
witcher 3 on my screen as well as taps
for recently added games the store page
meanwhile highlights the current deals
available along with other tabs for
things like new games top paid games
specials free games and more you can
customize what rows show up in your home
screen which is a nice option if you
don't want to be inundated by any
particular thing and as usual it bears
mentioning again here that you can
customize your background in colors as
well as the transparency levels of the
home panel and tiles those features
haven't gone away moving to the games
and apps UI you'll notice that the
grouping is improved it's now much
easier to navigate and see your games at
a glance yet you can tell I like sports
games and shooters there are also now
labels for trials and demos as you can
see here with plants vs. zombies battle
for neighbor Ville before this page
showed every game you owned or had
access to through Xbox Live Gold or game
paths and it was distracting and
overwhelming to see so much information
all at once now if you want to see your
full library you just click full library
given the increasing size of games these
days and the big patches that can make
them even bigger you're likely to need
to delete games in DLC often to free up
space the new update makes it easier by
showing you things like leftover add-ons
that you might have installed but never
used there is also a shrinkable games
tab that shows you games that can
decrease in file size while still being
played I don't have any of these but you
might
another new feature in the update is the
ability to view images and animated gifs
in messages on Xbox Live yes we're sure
nothing will go wrong here but also
don't worry in your privacy settings you
can select who is able to send you
messages another nice feature in the
Xbox one update is the ability to set
where notifications show up on your
screen there are six different locations
to choose from from across the screen
this is great because previously the
notifications could pop up in places
that would obscure the action on the
screen microsoft says your preferred
location will be the default but some
games may move the location to provide
the best user experience you can check
out the full blog post on Microsoft's
web site to see a rundown of everything
that's new in the update including
improvements a mixer and data storage
overall this new Xbox one dashboard is a
welcome improvement on what has
historically been a difficult to use
platform it still takes you more than a
few button presses to get where you want
to go and see what you want to see but I
like the strides Microsoft is made here
not only does the update give the Xbox
one a facelift it feels like the
dashboard is snappier and more
responsive this update is expected to
roll out to everyone in February so be
on the lookout for these features very
soon
you